it's 29 years since the legendary Smiths
split Johnny Marr was just 23 and now
he's keen to set the record straight
about breakups and possible makeups I
always had a real special kind of
feeling about him when I come out here a
lot the audience know that I'm from just
down the road so they know it's a proper
homecoming the break-up of any band as
any musician is Godfrey will tell you is
/ if Akande it's heartbreaking you know
and it absolutely was it was inevitable
without a Down if I'm going to tell the
life story I'm going to put it straight
the Smiths were only around for five
years during the 80s but made a profound
impact culturally and politically
massing is their privilege to rail
against the establishment at the time
when Margaret Thatcher came into power
suddenly young people and particularly
if you're in a band you had this sense
that you were really up against it I
just thought that society should look at
the people who were you need a helping
hand I still feel that way now and I
thought that they could serve to
government and the right-wing government
stood for the opposite of that and I
still do you famously said that Cameron
couldn't like the Smiths would you feel
differently about Corbin using your
songs I don't know whether there's
anyone in my mind that in the Labour
Party right now that I would actually
allow to give my songs to there are any
any politicians who are like at the
moment not one a reunion of the Smiths
was briefly on the cars in 2008 it's not
looking good for the future doing what
I'm doing I could only speak for myself
it doesn't feel like it's necessary at
all really reading interviews with
Morrissey he's talking about the fact
that regs it was magnificent Nigel
Farage is a great bloke it doesn't sound
like ideologically you have that much in
common anymore no that's probably right
yeah I always forget about now if it's
the case that he's Pro Faraj and then
you know that would be able to offer
slight kind of drawback in I think
as anyone can imagine Lisa Casa Sky News
Manchester
you